so I've recently been talking a little
bit more about cryptocurrency and we've
got an audience question about
cryptocurrency coming up on the Friday
program this week and a bunch of people
have emailed in and they've said David
the David Pakman show should do an IC
o---- and IC o---- what is an IC o----
an IC o---- relates to cryptocurrency
and it stands for initial coin offering
and if you know the term IPO an IPO is
an initial public offering when you've
got a private company and they want to
what's called go public they offer
shares of stock in the company and the
initial offering of that stock is called
an IPO after a company IPOs people can
go to whatever their broker is and they
can buy and sell shares of those
companies on the open market so an IC
o---- is similar to an IPO in that it's
the initial offering of a new
cryptocurrency and it's a way that money
can be raised through the initial sale
of crypto tokens in exchange for some
cryptocurrency
which is bought with cash it can be
built on Bitcoin increasingly these icos
are being built on aetherium which has a
platform that's really built for the
underlying built to work as the
underlying currency for a lot of these
initial coin offerings this is kind of
controversial actually there are some
who see these icos is fantastic
innovative ways for Ventures to raise
capital and fundraise and for efforts
like the david pakman show and
independent media to fund themselves
there are others though who see these
icos more as maybe dangerous ways for
huge amounts of capital to change hands
and get tied up in cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency that might have
questionable long-term value there's
legal questions there are regulatory
questions involving the SEC but I
actually have been thinking about and
have spoken to a couple people about the
david pakman show organizing an IC o----
but i have sort of no idea how we would
actually do it so my call to you is my
offer to people in the audience is if
you have expertise in this if you could
advise and guide me at least in the
initial
thought process of if and how we might
do an initial coin offering is it a good
idea is it a bad idea could you help
with the logistics of it what about the
possibility of a shared progressive ico
that could be done a cryptocurrency for
a group of progressive shows to raise
money together so that we might have
more total buy-in with cross-promotion I
don't know if someone is truly well
versed in this and could maybe guide or
help us or point us in the right
direction please get in touch we've got
a contact form you go to david
pakman.com click on contact at the top
of the page and send me a note with your
thoughts tell me whether this might be a
good idea if you think this is a
terrible idea tell me that as well tell
me how much you think or how we might
estimate how much money we might be able
to raise through an ICO should we build
it on a theorem or some other underlying
cryptocurrency a lot of questions but
I'll tell you I'm being totally upfront
I am way out of my league in actually
being able to organize this and carry it
out myself so please get in touch if you
think it's a good idea I'd appreciate
hearing from you maybe also we can
create a reddit discussion thread about
this if somebody's listening and is on
the reddit david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT is the address for our reddit and
you can also make a post there with your
thoughts about a david pakman show or
progressive media coin offering we'll be
back after this